[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui parle alimentation cuisine
gastronomie française aujourd'hui
puisque nous recevons et yannick alléno
c'est vous qui allez passer sur le grill
est avec moi pour présenter cette
émission jean-pierre montanay bonjour
jean pierre bonjour brigitte bonjour
yannick alléno jean pierre bonjour
yannick alléno vous êtes chef cuisinier
membres de ce cercle très fermé des deux
fois trois étoiles où l'on trouve
quelques rares noms prestigieux comme
ducasse verra au robuchon trois étoiles
donc au pavillon ledoyen à paris en 1947
à courchevel mais c'est tout juste 40
ans que vous décrocher les trois
macarons vous êtes à l'époque au meurice
apprenti pâtissier au lutétia vous
débutez votre carrière au royal monceau
avant de poursuivre sofitel deux-sèvres
chez drouant et à l'hôtel scribe en 2015
nouvelle consécration vous êtes élu
cuisinier de l'année par le endroit
harper et le gault et millau héros de la
gastronomie française vous surprenez en
vous installant à marrakech à dubaï à
pékin et à taïwan et encore plus en
ouvrons la bis un bar à sushi au
pavillon ledoyen qui décroche une étoile
est en fait l'établissement indépendant
le plus étoilé du monde alors qu'est ce
qu'on va déguster aujourd'hui
jean-pierre pour ce déjeuner est
bienvenu ambiance japonaise avec boeuf
omar et tonci raffy à la parisienne et
en dessert rhubarbe cuite en croûte de
sucre sorbet à l'oseille et finger vote
croustillantes n'en jetez plus parce que
c'est le chef qui régale exactement dans
le dos ou des plats à l'insertion par la
cuisine la passerelle handicap propose
des formations à des personnes en
situation de handicap une voie royale
pour intégrer pourquoi pas la brigade du
pavillon ledoyen deux doyens sous la
houlette de yannick alléno reportage
dans cette émission dont les pieds dans
le plat quel est le secret d'un chocolat
artisanal reportage chez un chocolatier
qui s'occupe de tout de la fève torréfié
à la tablette à croquer allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidences
[Musique]
brigitte recevoir yannick alléno à notre
table ici dans les sous-sols du palais
bourbon c'est comme si on accueillait
messi pour jouer au foot dans les
jardins de l'assemblée la star mondiale
le génie argentin avec ses sept ballons
d'or et vous avec vos neuf étoiles comme
l'a rappelé brigitte alors messi sur la
pelouse nous aurait fait admirer sa
technique balle au pied à passements de
jambes double contact amorti bref
ambiance ligue des champions et bien
pareil avec vous ambiance gastro
fusionnent foot comme on dit vous êtes
un des cuisines et cadors de la planète
le prince des sauces alors en grand
seigneur vous avez débarqué ici avec une
partie de votre riche répertoire avec
l'art du contre-pied à la messi on
imaginait découvrir la grande cuisine
française avec un plat signature
pourquoi pas des ris de veau raffiné
mais clivant mais non vous le chef globe
crocker vous dégainez donc votre savoir
faire japonais de l'abysse le comptoir à
sushis avec un boeuf omar est ton en
chie rachis à la parisienne alors
faudrait savoir un japonais français ou
les deux à la fois capitaine les deux à
la fois en fait ces restaurants l'abysse
et un restaurant de rencontre avec notre
chef
okazaki il ya son mari qui nous arrive
de tokyo il ya cinq ans maintenant donc
il ya eu le courage de partir de
s'exiler de venir c'est la première fois
que le monial japonais à partir non pas
du tout non non non non mais c'est vrai
que c'est aussi à vous imaginer et
partir de son pays natal pour aller
exercer son art en france quand on parle
pas la langue
quand on a pas ni la culture ni
10 conséquent ceux qui en france est en
fait il a eu le cran de venir en lui a
fait un restaurant qui a été dessiné par
mon épouse laurence un truc très moderne
magnifique et puis finalement au gré du
travail on a obtenu très vite deux
étoiles au guide michelin est donc ici
ça représente un peu ce qu'est cette
rencontre évidemment le le taillage
précis l'utilisation de la spéciale à
des coupes c'est l'agrément de d 2 quad
du vinaigre
la cuisine japonaise chacune du temps
c'est dire que le fait de la maturité
est important c'est un poisson il n'est
pas consommée comme sa sortie de l'eau y
ont fait des poissons qui s'appelle etc
et j'y mets ces morts vivants se dire
qu'on les a écrits fille d'une certaine
façon pour que les toxines du stress ne
n'atteignent pas les chair du poisson ce
qui permet de comme une viande de
conserver le poisson un peu plus
longtemps et en fonction du temps que
nous choisissons nous avons à chercher
plus ou moins d'acides plus ou moins de
profondeur et finalement le shiraishi ce
qui veut dire le sushi éparpillés
représente un peu peut-être une
intelligence de cuisson de l'agrémenter
des allées des aliments comme ça qu'ils
s'impliquent père écologique en fait
mais qu'elle a elle-même parisienne dans
ce shiraishi puisqu ils arriveront vers
ax et un plat japonais à qui remonte à
plusieurs siècles mais vous votre pâte
donc shiraishi c'est quoi ce chirac
celle en l'occurrence c'est l'ingrédient
principal du séraphine sellerie yasunari
lui valent cuire dans une eau spécifique
il va le sucre et va le psy du lait avec
un vinaigre de riz moi j'ai choisi de le
faire en pilaf c'est à dire avec une
échalote et un oignon au fonds du ce et
on a créé le riz et on vient le bouillet
avec un peu de vin blanc et d'un et d'un
bouillon de volaille heures on va goûter
ça parce qu'au fond nous opposer à fait
mis en appétit cédait 7 voient déjà les
couleurs sont magnifiques il ya des
dégradés de rouge de rose de faire
attention l'été arrive donc on n'est pas
trop grave accueilli en ce moment
alors ça il ya des petits de dassault
monde chaque bouchée elle va partir dans
des différentes et un peu de brochets
fumée et un peu de croustillant il ya un
peu de ses rôties le riz qui amène
finalement le tenue du plat donc on se
balade entre llyod
llyod et la mer mais la mer est là et la
terre en fait c'est un peu ce que quand
on travaille à bordeaux on connaît bien
cela et c'est cette rencontre de la
terre et de la mer c'est toujours
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire et
ça c'est un plat qu'on vous commande
souvent c'est assez emblématique faire
des best-sellers moi j'utilise que du
caviar français j'y tiens entre avec la
maison prunier
et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui les produits
que nous produisons même sur les sur les
caviars sont extraordinaires alors je
leur ai donné trois petits d'indications
sur le shiraishi puisque yannick alléno
se sert de ce mot japonais de cette
recette japonaise pour en faire une
extrapolation un peu francisé mais on
ressent quand même les accents japonais
aussi dans ce plat c'est délicieux alors
le chirac si on dit aussi chira shih tzu
chi li brigitte c'est une recette
traditionnelle de la cuisine nippone
faciles à préparer ces daims des plats
préférés d'ailleurs des japonais c'est
un plat populaire qui remonteraient à la
période edo entre 500 et mille huit cent
soixante huit ans et ceux qui
fréquentent les restaurants japonais
connaissent bien ce grand bol de riz
assaisonner au vinaigre à vous l'avez
dit yannick sur lequel on a éparpillé
plein de choses en fait on peut aussi
finir le placard avec ça le chi rachis
est un plat froid alors parmi ses gagne
ses garnitures des sashimis bien sûr ce
sont des fines tranches de poisson cru
comme le saumon le thon le maquereau la
daurade des crustacés vous avez une il
assèche du poulpe cuit cette fois puis
également des concombres des avocats des
algues nori des champignons shiitake
bref on peut y mettre beaucoup de choses
si vous voulez faire à chirac chirac
chez la maison c'est pas compliqué
suffit d'acheter du riz japonais peut le
faire cuire à un peu dans l'eau très un
peu delteil de le mélanger avec un peu
de vinaigre de riz a pas de vinaigre de
vin et puis après vous allez chez votre
poissonnier et vous lui demander de
couper quelques tranches de saumon ou de
ou de thon cru et vous avez votre effet
japonais à la maison comme ici sur ce
plateau mais pourquoi vous êtes
intéressé à la cuisine asiatique comme
ça et particulièrement japonais c'est là
vous direz que c'est la meilleure
cuisine du monde ou
si tu c'est une très belle cuisine
certes j'estime qu'une française
l'avenir quid du monde il ya plein de
belles cuisines en fête comme les bocuse
il ya deux cuisines la mauvaise est la
bonne et moi je m'intéresse aussi à tout
ce qui est bon le japon 18 ans je suis
parti pour la première fois à sapporo
donc on était passé par encore et je
voyage durer 24 heures ce qui va nous
arriver maintenant le fait de
l'actualité mais et j'ai découvert moi
j'étais un élève de fin sur un enfant
delà du steak frites à mes parents
tenaient des bistrots et ségou là je ne
les connaissais pas ça a été une vraie
révélation choc et ne rencontre c'est un
choc enfin je veux dire le japon est un
pays extrêmement moderne qui a gardé
vraiment l'ancrage dans ce qu'il est
c'est fantastique il faut absolument
y aller or pour comprendre et moi quand
j'ai voulu faire ce bar à sushis il
était pour moi hors de question que de
faire de trahir cette culture qu'il
fallait le faire hyper bien chez vécu
cinq jours avec le bizutage nissan qui
était le l'élève de jirau san le fameux
maître sushi trois étoiles de tokyo il
un restaurant dans un métro l'a trahie
et 25 ans est restée en dessous et pour
parer pour pas lui faire de l'ombre il
est parti à yokohama une heure de train
de tokyo tous les jours il faisait des
allers-retours en dessous de sookie ji
le marché aux poissons et son restaurant
et un jour après dix ans il a décidé que
sa pénitence et est enfin faite il est
revenu à tokyo à ginza requise à ces
champs elysées de la grippe b tokyo il
avait qu'une seule troubles j'essaie
d'avoir trois étoiles avant son maître
eu non mais c'est incroyable et donc il
est il les a eus en même temps et le
même jour donc il était soulagé ils
étaient soulagés donc moi je suis partie
avec lui j'ai vécu une semaine chez lui
on a dormi sur les tatamis il m'a
expliqué qu'elle est inscrite dans
sushis en fait c'est pas aussi simple
que ça en a l'air c'est très codé la
cuisine japonaise a comme la société
d'ailleurs tous égaux des bonds s'est
réduit à dellys double le sushi est né
en chine il faut le savoir
mais c'était à l'origine à à un aliment
de voyage on mettait ça dans des
barriques le riz servait de tampon et il
mettait du sel sur le sur le sur le
poisson pour le conserver pour aller
pêcher et ensuite le vinaigre et le sac
est un fantastique des salons si vous
avez des sales et quelque chose vous
faites un mélange vinaigre sac et 50 50
et vous plonger dedans quelque chose ça
va se décider très vite et donc il faut
être consommée dans sa le riz le poisson
en partant travailler elle a évidemment
tout tient tout repose finalement sur le
poisson vous vous allez vous
approvisionnez ou en fait alors on a
c'était assez étonnant de ce qu'on colle
yasunari est arrivé les circuits
d'approvisionnement ne sont pas du tout
les mêmes en france donc il a eu un choc
quand il arrivait à rungis évidemment
parce que là-bas le poisson est un truc
vraiment particulier et nous on a on a
des réseaux directs avec les pêcheurs
donc je lui dis patients tu verras tu
vas tu vas connaître l'ensemble des
pêcheurs donc que quand on reçoit un ton
très exigeant sur le ton ça vient de
méditerranée barbe athée sévit un peu la
tunisie parfois ça dépend mais
ça vaut une fortune pas se le cacher
c'est au marché au japon a auprès son os
ça peut atteindre des prix records il ya
des enchères et c'est monté jusqu'à deux
millions trois cent cinquante mille
euros et 1 350 kg j'ai vu sa main et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose mais
encore une fois la notion de sacrifice
de ce poisson
a une forte valeur chez eux je trouve
que c'est on devrait s'en inspirer
parfois alors au pavillon ledoyen on
trouve pas que ça quels sont vos plats
signatures alors moi je déteste de
parler de plats signature parce que ça
nous enferme toujours dans une boîte en
a3 lieu dans la maison on a le pavillon
qui est un comptoir gastronomique où là
on vient manger une cuisine viré de
bistrot à améliorer on a une étoile au
guide michelin donc c'est devenu un peu
la table du cac 40 les gens se régale à
venir chez nous c'est plus simple c'est
la gastronomie sans cravate le sushi qui
s'appelle alice alors là on est dans
l'extrême on a vingt couverts par
service
avec une collection de sacs et jamais
égalée en france et puis à l'étagé on
avait six mois la bombe à bissau non non
pas six mois non non non non non mais il
faut il faut il faut anticiper nommé
dans la semaine c'est sur c'est complet
semaine sur l'autre mais non là et
ensuite le 3 étoiles en eau qui est le
temps de la gastronomie et finalement le
laboratoire de recherche de mai avancés
culinaire ici on a inventé les sources
modernes et nouvelle sauce ici on a
inventé la pâtisserie sans sucre ici on
a inventé la chocolaterie là le jour et
a requis sans sucre donc on essaye de
content de vous voir et vous régaler
gens piratent
hommage aux paillettes vous parlez mais
le des sujets pour manger je me régale
le ca à ça et puis après il ya les
événementiels qui ont oublié on a on à
105 ans est employé dans cette maison
c'est devenu une belle à une belle
maison et j'en suis très content et très
fier et vous vos inspirations et vous
viennent d'où qu'on vous dit on invente
on cherche toujours des idées nouvelles
ça c'est quoi c'est l'air du temps c'est
en voyageant d'où tout ça vient c'est un
mécanisme un peu complexe la créativité
d'un muscle en plus on va créer plus on
va se muscler et plus on va en faire et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui j'ai la maturité
nécessaire pour entendre ce que le
produit à vous dire une noix de saint
jacques c'est pas une noix de saint
jacques une noix de saint-jacques elle
peut grandir dans la baie d'erquy ou
sous les côtes bretonnes ou même de
l'autre côté de la manche elle n'aura
pas la même note elle n'aura pas le même
discours donc il faut savoir l'entendre
et d'adapter en fait sa main par rapport
à cela c'est extrêmement important de
comprendre ça et de prendre le temps de
parler aux produits en fait c'est lui
qui va vous dire ah ben voilà fais moi
s'il fait moins ça moi j'ai découvert
les saint-jacques me dire arrête de
mettre dans une poêle arrête de me 2 me
brutaliser comme ça donc les
saint-jacques aujourd'hui je les cuis
sur un sur un petit récipient métallique
avec un petit peu de vin blanc et je
m'en sers comme une cloche comme ça donc
la vapeur
saint jacques
j'ai encore une fois je sais ce que je
ne fera plus jamais mais je sais pas si
c'est une hérésie chacun fait ce qu'il
veut et
mais je trouve que c'est un mollusque eu
tellement délicat qu'il faut y faire
attention à peine cuite en fait presque
cru non ouais alors à la maison c'est
assez simple vous prenez ça m'est témoin
je mets un peu un peu d'échalotes un peu
de vin blanc une pointe de curry parfois
et de l'eau je fais bouillir le liquide
je mets la cendre est dessus vous
comptez trois minutes trois minutes vous
la retourne et elle est allée
parfaitement cuite le liquide il est
parfaitement réduit vont était un tout
petit peu de beurre et ou services
assouad saint jacques vous allez obtenir
une recette mais vraiment incroyable
donc aujourd'hui quand je comprends ça
je me dis que je j'ai plus envie de de
la delà de la brusquer comme ça mais il
ya une chose un peu paradoxal c'est que
vous êtes le maître des sauces et en
même temps vous dites il faut retrouver
le goût du produit est ce que la sauce
justement n'a pas souvent masqué un peu
le look le pur en fait le goût du
produit pur qu'on connaît la sauce elles
s'utilisent
c'est un peu le vert de la cuisine
française c'est quand vous écrivez des
démos vous avez besoin de verbes vous
avez besoin de temps passé composé
la sauce et ça ça va marquer le temps
qu'il faut savoir le guide escoffier
canton louvre
l'introduction sur la sauce est
édifiante de vérité elle amène la
complexité la cuisse et laurent par en
fait à toute intrusion de cuisine
étrangère aujourd'hui on attend avec
beaucoup de respect une intrusion
nordique extraordinaire dans la cuisine
en france
alors c'est super bien fait et je suis
pas là pour critiquer quoi que ce soit
mais quand on regarde ça on se dit que
autant d'escoffier on avait la sauce
suprême
on allait chercher du poivron à
albufeira et en plus la france rendait
hommage au pays d'origine du produit et
quand dans les années 80 il ya eu il ya
eu deux arrêts de la sauce des années 80
où avec la cuisine la nouvelle cuisine
nouvelle cuisine ego et mieux on a été
un des fossoyeurs a dit il faut arrêter
de faire des sauces et c'est parce qu'on
n'a pas de réponse à la légèreté et
finalement ils n'étaient pas réalisés
avec un contre les autres une chance
qu'il ait pas de réponse à la légèreté
et puis il ya eu un autre phénomène qui
était la guerre du golfe ça paraît
étonnant mais la guerre du golfe dans
les années 90 a mis un coup d'arrêt au
régime social
comprend pas très bien pourquoi pourquoi
parce que dans les établissements les
derniers soucier restant en france était
dans les palaces et ça a été un désastre
économique pour les hôtels et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est à l'époque où les
anglais
sont arrivés avec leurs habitudes de
cause que de cost killer c'est vraiment
des grands financiers et d'ailleurs
c'est là où tout la dorchester
collection a racheté les palaces 1 on a
eu le plaza athénée le meurice où
j'étais le chef et les gars qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait maison regarder dans le
pétrole est ce qui coûte cher les saurez
ce qui coûte cher ils ont fait vous avez
un chef saucier qu'à 55 ans le mec il
cher et puis il demande la meilleure
marchandises ben voilà et puis forte des
gens donc vous irez ça et vous allez
gagner 20% sauf qu'on a perdu énormément
dans le côté on à paris on a perdu notre
côté culturel social c'est là où son
arrivée vous devez vous en rappeler les
traits de balsamique dans les aciers hle
réduit et dynamique à tous les étages
c'est ouf et et l'introduction de la
sauce soja aussi c'est avant on aurait
filtré on l'aurait on l'aurait intégré
mais là on en a commencé à mettre de
l'huile d'olive un peu de sel un peu de
gingembre et ça faisait vinaigrette un
peu ma l'air et donc on avait perdu
beaucoup et moi je me suis mise comme
challenge de reproposer
de la sauce mais moderne cercle de la
rampe le remplacer le savoir-faire par
un process et de donner du temps aux
cuisines réfléchir leur créativité mais
d'avoir une palette comme ça alors
dispositions exceptionnelles pour
redonner du sens rené de licence à la
table la table ce n'est pas simplement
une assiette pas simplement à plat la
taxe et le vin aussi dire que quand vous
aurez a bien sûr un grand cordon moi je
suis je suis pas favorable au micro
dégustation de 25 vert pendant un repas
je trouve que on finit par y perdre et
perdre du sens mais quand vous avez un
très grand vin avec sa complexité et qui
finalement le vin avec son oxygénation
le temps qui changent et cetera la
température montante change de goût il
faut que nous le cuisinier ce soyons
capables de mettre en face une cuisine
qui répond à ça et le seul élément qui
va pouvoir faire en sorte qu elle lui en
se passe entre le vin le seul élément
qui va faire en sorte que les éléments
se parle dans une assiette c'est la
sauce voilà donc j'ai travaillé là
dessus et franchement c'est génial on
est sûr que vous êtes incollables mais
on va quand même passé au quiz
j'avais deux quiz brigitte mais je vais
changer l'ordre parce que on va comme ça
sans transition enchaîné avec les sauts
avec les sauts soit là vous le roi de la
sauce seriez vous nous dire quelle sauce
se cache derrière ces quatre
affirmations son inventeur et charles de
rohan ministre de louis 15 elle est
préparée avec des oignons elle ressemble
à un coulis est-ce que fièvre en faire
une recette culte notamment pour
accompagner des oeufs pochés vous en
parliez d'escoffier d elle a aujourd'hui
disparu un peu des tables des grands
chefs with
leur oasis accolade sur la sauce et
vous qui avez lancé votre propre
boutique on va voir si vous êtes
incollables sur le chocolat qui est
inventé le chocolat à croquer sous forme
de tablette à john cadbury b van houten
c'est antoine meunier aidé francis
graille frei
sui sont
bons je suis pas que la suisse dans
l'es4 tous les cas y ait un anglais il
ya un fort nous tel il doit être
hollandais robben van houten aller non
non non c'est pas van uden c'est antoine
meunier
ah oui il est sympa c'est lui qui a
inventé la barre cylindrique et celui
qui l'a vraiment exploiter un peu
industriellement ensuite c'est entre
francis frei qui était le premier
chocolatier et lui c'était un
britannique et qui a fait du chocolat
peu industriels mais celui qui a eu
l'idée de le faire sous forme de
tablette au départ je pense qu'il était
pharmacien et guérissait quelques mots
avec du chocolat c'est normal c'est
cette même
nom le chocolat menier d'ailleurs c'est
vrai qu'il existe encore mais je pense
qu'on reproduit et
dites nous quels sont les chefs qui vous
ont le plus marqué dans votre aventure
plan
c'est difficile d'en extraire que
quelques-uns mais il ya eu déjà tous
mais m j'ai été formé par six meilleurs
ouvriers de france c'est pas rien
jacky fréon premier bocuse d'or en 87
quand j'étais apprenti pâtissier au
lutetia et je vois jacky frais ont passé
avec son trophée
compression de césar mais si un jour
j'irai faire ce concours c'est la
première fois je voyais tous les grands
chefs débarqué dans la cuisine et bocuse
robuchon tout le monde
qui étaient autour de
bassila dans ces cas là non j'étais
admiratif croire c'est extraordinaire et
votre mentor celui qui dont vous
regardez souvenir le plus puissant louis
grondard choix palau livrons d'harwell
ou grandes arrête un pareil et lui il
m'a réappris à refaire je travaillais
chez mes 25 ans quand je suis arrivé
chez lui
mse la main sur l'épaule lundi menant à
faire la cuisine j'ai commencé à 15 ans
de bon et là effectivement on a repris
tout ou lescoffier ensemble toutes les
sauces les grandes gelées disons pour
elle de l'air de dire vous avez fait dit
rien mais presque a pour rien mais au
moins il m'a mis le nez sur l'évidence
il ya eu
il ya encore un restaurant qu'il faut
absolument aller voir c'est le
restaurant de louis ii le relais louis
xiii avec manuel martinez vous mangez la
plus belle cuisine classique française
chez manuel martinez donc il faut aller
les quenelles de bach sont un monument
alors lui j'ai j'ai commencé par lui en
fait un sacré personnage ouais il est
génial et génial et puis c'est un type
tellement effectif un peu un peu un peu
voyeur comme celui de la gouaille mais
alors vous savez qu'en france le repas
occupent une large place donc on a
souvent des histoires qui se raconte
autour des repas c'est la brève de
comptoir
et où vous a demandé yannick alléno de
réfléchir à une histoire qui vous a
marqué autour d'un déjeuner ou d'un
dîner est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
raconter une brève de comptoir il y en a
plus y en a plein - le look orient dans
mail en fait la brève que j'aimerais
vivre ça serait de faire revenir à autre
la table
chapelle
bocuse robuchon et faire un repas un peu
imaginaire comme ça et de leur demander
finalement
gens de laval le sorcier de bougival
j'ai les 18 ans un jour et puis il me
met le nez dans les yeux rôle unique à
ce que tu son petit
j'étais impressionné parce que le type
était assez grande et grandes lunettes
et aux
forêts non
parce que ça va elphège ménard ya
réfléchi bien et tout et c'est là où
peut-être j'ai commencéà aussi à
comprendre le produit et 10 à 100
l'abricot
effectivement ces girolles avait une
note d'abricots il me dit quand vous
fusille de l'abricot la cuisson va faire
évaporer mettez un petit beurre
d'abricots pour pensez ce que vous avez
perdu
j'aimerais y arracher deux mille
questions à tous leur poser parce qu'ils
sont partis avec des choses escoffier
j'aimerais j'aimerais leur dire demander
des choses et si vous faisait signer là
vous leur sert verrier quoi je leur
ferai j'ai sorti un truc c'est l'oeuf
badaboum j'ai réussi à farcir l'oeuf
avant le pocher de caviar et d'ailleurs
il ya eu un changement dit avec ça parce
que tous les copains m'ont envoyé il a
dit essayer de le faire ici de le faire
jusqu'à temps qu'ils y arrivent donc je
recevais des images de tokyo deux de
taïwan de est légal il fait ça y est j'y
suis arrivé et alors ces techniques et y
est tout bête un an mais l'oeuvre dans
sa dans un dans un récipient mais qu'il
faut vraiment très fortement le glacé en
dessous qu'est ce que le que la nuit le
blanc d'oeuf soit très saisie comme ça
et on vient percer l'oeuvre comme ça et
on farci de foire mais on met 8 grammes
de foie gras de caviar dedans et ensuite
on le poche donc le fils est
parfaitement pocher bien rond et quand
vous le creuset comme ça il savait
s'éparpille alors badaboum pourquoi
parce que on a une association qui
s'appelle la bab avec mon copain
alexandre bader c'est donc ça veut dire
la bande à baader et nous avons et nous
avons l'habitude de faire des
choses comme ça pour aller chercher de
quoi financer des chambres stériles pour
l'hôpital trousseau et donc à chaque
fois qu'on lui qui a marqué par dix et
badaboum c'est pour ça que ça peut
décidément trop fidèle à ses engagements
on va en parler d'ailleurs puisque
l'insertion des personnes en situation
de handicap passe aussi par la cuisine
une intégration qui nécessite à tous de
s'adapter c'est le dessous des plats
la passerelle handicap est un dispositif
développé par la région ile de france et
qui offre une formation à des personnes
en situation de handicap l'objectif
apprendre un métier par la pratique en
milieu professionnel du centre de
formation au restaurant étoilé ces
jeunes se forment à la cuisine ou au
service en salle en tant que parrain de
la promotion 2020 vous yannick alléno
vous avez donné une chance à ces jeunes
reportage hélène bonduelle antoine
scrutin on se concentre sur ce qu'on
fait à l'est et bien droites allouche
voilà au centre et tu tournes en même
temps à poil profil inversé voilà tout
doucement tout doucement il faut répéter
les mouvements un lassabe le mans pour
lohan atteint de dyspraxie qu ils
peinent dans les gestes les plus
quotidiens
donc c'est sa difficulté que le cerveau
coordonne les deux actions en même temps
laurent d'elijah renseigne depuis six
ans à la passerelle handicap de cette
école de cuisine cinq apprentis sont en
formation tous porteurs d'un handicap
mais il s'accroche avec un objectif
intégrer le monde du travail elisa de
séparer les jaunes et les blancs d'oeuf
dans un tamis
comme enfin le blanc d'abord le et je
sais pas en fait on perd et cuisine donc
dépit dossier je vais faire cuisiner
aussi comme lui parce que j'aime bien ce
que fera goûter et montrer aux gens ce
qu'il sait faire ou à rennes lui veut
être serveur et aujourd'hui ils
s'entraînent au dressage de la table
alors pour l'instant c'est bien marc
goua gohou au moins 3,4 chose
proche n'est pas propre donc bon on
l'enlève et c'est un métier qui demande
du travail
la rapidité de la réaction des
anticipations aux côtés de ces jeunes
apprentis le premier maître d'hôtel de
matignon la résidence du premier
ministre
le formateur et bienveillant mais
exigent aussi le but qu'on a c'est de
les emmener dans milieu ordinaire qui
travaillent dans des restaurants
classiques comme comme beaucoup d'autres
c'est pas forcément de mieux protéger
les wines afrique apapreils demain dans
un restaurant et pourquoi pas dans un
restaurant étoilé comme walid
nos craintes et les cuivres ont atteint
de troubles autistiques
il est depuis six mois un commis de
salle au pavillon ledoyen embauchés en
cdi mais attention notamment aux petites
taches de rouille d'accord il en avait
eu un bug c'était un petit peu
ici ils travaillent en binôme avec tom
et se perfectionne chaque jour
franchement j'aime j'aimerais lui dire
bah merci beaucoup parce que franchement
c'est que c'est que c'est grâce à lui
que je suis plus haut autonome vous
voyez
qu est-ce qui m'apprend valide il
m'apprend être toujours souriant ça nous
permet de mieux travailler ensemble de
favoriser le vivre ensemble sans
paiement comment un jeune qui a un léger
en handicap et peut aller aussi haut et
est aussi assis ou est aussi ou aussi
loin que ça vous allez rire de votre eau
et bocaux le chef triplement étoilé
yannick alléno ainsi recruté quatre
stagiaires porteurs de handicap et 4
millions cd et ces équipes-là sûr cela a
fait évoluer les méthodes de management
c'est à dire davantage soigner sa
communication comment je m'adresse à
l'autre finalement quand on est une
équipe relativement jeune on doit
apprendre les codes notamment du luxe
c'est très important visiblement ça
marche le pavillon ledoyen est en phase
de nouveaux recrutements de personnels
en situation de handicap
yannick alléno vous venez voir ce
reportage pourquoi vous avez fait ce
choix là vous d'intégrer ces personnes
en situation de handicap à ce que
j'imagine que quand c'est le coup de feu
que il faut aller vite c'est pas évident
non plus de brusques et peut-être un peu
ces personnes là je vous réponde je
pense que je me demande pourquoi je n'ai
pas fait avant
parce que je crois que nos métiers ne
serviront à quelque chose que si
justement on fait en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de gens en dehors de la société et
notre investissement au travers nos
engagements
donne donne des résultats qui sont assez
spectaculaires
sa réussite tout le monde ça marche il
enrichit les collaborateurs qui
finalement
ont beaucoup plus de bienveillance
vis-à-vis des les uns des autres et donc
moi je suis hyper satisfait alors
rentrer dans ce genre de démarche s'est
passé pas si ça moi j'ai eu des grosses
craintes et sophie cluzel qui est
ministre chargé et déléguée au handicap
tu feras des bêtises pas grave fais-le
et montre l'exemple voilà donc offrir
ainsi personne à la maison ils
comptaient en intégrer d'autres ouais
bien sûr et bien sûr non mais en plus
souvent non là on a pas que ça on a on a
plusieurs établissements en france et
tout donc on va continuer évidemment à
leur donner
un jeune joueur qui m'a dit c'est ce qui
ce qui est plus fort pour moi c'est de
de toucher un salaire un vrai salaire
mes parents se sont tellement sacrifié
pour moi
avoir des conséquences même informé il a
prononcé les mots bienveillants c'est ce
qu'on n'assiste pas avec ce reportage
est très touchant à un tournant parce
que il ya encore quelques années le
milieu de la cuisine c'était plutôt
discipline de fer brigade brimades
parfois harcèlement est ce que là on
n'assiste pas à un renversement de la
tendance et des comportements en cuisine
c'est celui que vous vous les
accompagnez way et puis moi ça m'est
arrivé j'ai eu des problèmes aussi dans
ma carrière et je les assume
dans l'évolution des mentalités je veux
dire on a été levée une certaine façon
c'est pas pour autant que le 20e siècle
le futur se prépare de la même façon
vous avez été trop dur parfois en
cuisine on se doute bien trop dur et
vous même vous avez subi des brimades
fin c'était difficile encore une fois
c'est vrai c'est une autre époque ce
qu'on a vécu est une autre époque moi
j'ai commencé à bosser j'ai 15 ans les
cuisiniers n'était pas forcément du
niveau d'érudition que les jeunes que
nous avons aujourd'hui tout a évolué et
moi j'avais besoin de cadres je suis
arrivé dans les brialy perdu aïder dur
dur dur et j'avais besoin de cas j'étais
un garçon a plutôt indisciplinés et
c'est ce qui m'a aussi permis d'en
arriver là donc non mais s'est reproduit
le modèle c'est ça on peut reproduire le
modèle et puis vous savez à temps il
faut aussi réfléchir à une cause la
présence et la cause dans un restaurant
gastronomique imaginez vous le vendredi
soir avec la pression du résultat
vous avez 45 couverts à servir qui
arrivent tous entre 20h30 20h45 qui sont
affamés moi je sais pas comment vous
êtes vous êtes affamés mais les gens
sont sont eux sont d'une base et
agressivité c'est impressionnant
c'est l'histoire humaine comme ça c'est
pas chez moi plus qu'un autre on a faim
on a faim et puis et puis on s'est tapé
une heure de bagnols et puis il a plu et
puis et puis enfin tout ça et tout le
monde arrive en même temps
la personne qui prend le stress et le
directeur de salle
il faut qu'il prenne les commandes de
tout le monde j'ai soif j'ai faim tout
en même temps qu' un stade donc on
essaie de structurer ensuite les ordres
arrive dans une cuisine de 50 m² avec 20
personnes à l'intérieur
et puis la pression monte et puis et
puis et puis à un moment donné je ne
vois pas comment une allumette coca lui
mais c'est une cocotte minute c'était
une cocotte minute et moi il m'est
arrivé parfois évidemment d'avoir des
mots peut-être déplacer et autres comme
je suis pas le seul encore une fois il
faut assumer ses bêtises et je me suis
ok comment on peut réagir en fait pour
faire les choses autres j'écris un livre
notamment sur la conciergerie table
auparavant vous receviez nouveaux
clients dans votre restants ils vous
téléphonez il vous demander deux ou
trois couverts oui monsieur très bien à
qui alors voulez-vous venir 20h30 comme
tout le monde mais ans et puis est-ce
que je peux avoir votre numéro de carte
bleue et nous raccrochons le téléphone
les gens arrivent et on les connaissait
pas alors aujourd'hui on propose un
rendez vous et on leur demande plein de
choses ce qu'on est dans l'intimité on
peut se parler les allergies est ce que
vous avez envie de parler de vos
allergies dont tout le monde est-ce que
et et nunc je suis foule végétarien ok
donc ça nous laisse le temps de travail
etc et finalement de descendre la
pression de garder une tension reçoit
anticiper davantage finalement c'est
formidable c'est formidable le vin le
client aime certains à certains
champagnes il arrive il est dans la
glace on a préparé ses canapés pour
qu'ils puissent les avoir immédiatement
avec son vin servi immédiatement tout le
monde se calme et vous arrivez dans une
espèce d'organisation différentes mais
alors moi c'est le co vite il m'a permis
d'avoir le temps d'y réfléchir je me
suis posé pendant trois mois j'ai dit
comment je peux réfléchir à mon métier
différemment et comment je peux
finalement amené quiétude dans ma maison
parce que finalement l'agressivité les
gens sont pas agressives de façon
naturelle c'est pas vrai et et j'avais
envie vraiment de faire changer ça comme
ça et vous pensez que votre travail et
mieux fait défaut aujourd'hui mais c'est
incroyable il est notamment mieux fait
les gens ont le temps de s'occuper des
autres il n'ya plus le stress en fait et
on arrive à créer un meilleur travail
même une régularité plus importante je
dirais même
de préparer les vins en avance nadal est
un ouvrier un vin le matin pour le
servir le soir il est dans sa plénitude
tout le monde y gagne tout le monde y
gagne et très honnêtement je suis très
content
très content d'être passé par ces étapes
pour comprendre et préparer l'avenir de
ce métier voilà et si c'est pas moi qui
le fait qu'il va le faire en fait et
aujourd'hui on le voit franchement c'est
c'est formidable et donc ça passe aussi
par l'intégration de ces gens là ces
personnes en situation de handicap quel
regard portent les clients s'attend pas
forcément à trouver ces personnes là
devant vous dans des restaurants trois
étoiles non il ya de la bienveillance
aussi comme attention leur dit lilian un
handicap c'est la moitié il faut se
mettre aussi ça dans la tête la moitié
des handicapés sont des handicapés de la
vie des gens qui arrivent au monde avec
des handicaps il ya des gens qui
deviennent handicapés
50%
la société aujourd'hui n'est pas
forcément adaptée à ceux ci donc on doit
travailler fortement là dessus pour que
tous intègrent que ce soit le même monde
en fait on vit pas dans un monde
différent donc on doit faire des efforts
tous ensemble et moi j'ai reçu des
messages extraordinaire nos clients de
confrères qui m'ont dit je n'osais pas
le faire je vais m'y mettre quand je
vois michael à aux sushis qui a quatre
heures de concentration qui fait un
service impeccable après c'est plus
compliqué mais bon ça date est plus
longue peut-être ça prend du temps
ça prend encore une fois chaque individu
à
asson à son niveau de handicap donc il
faut qu'on s'adapte énormément par
rapport à ça mais franchement je suis
hyper hyper fier de mes équipes dans
dans leur implication de tous et je dis
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus une option
que la mémorisation non ce n'est pas une
obligation c'est une option on s'y met
tous et finalement enfin on et 150 on
arrive encadré 6 à 7 personnes sans
aucun problème allez on va parler de
pâques qui approche
son orgie de chocolat pour les français
qui en raffole le chocolat autant qu'un
savoir faire mais tous ne partent pas de
la fève de cacao alors on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
oui en cette période de pâques et en le
chocolat s'invite dans nos assiettes
nous avons décidé de nous intéresser à
l'aristocratie des chocolatiers ceux qui
transforment eux mêmes les fèves ils
sont à peine une centaine en france
comme ce couple d'origine du venezuela
installé à paris c'est un reportage de
marion becker et d'antoine coûteux
je m'appelle un dress accord est moins
mon époux sont ouverts à chocolat depuis
2015 on est un cheval die torréfacteur
ça veut dire qui en achètent les fesses
des cas quand on fait nous même notre
propre chocolat c'est ce qu'on appelle
le bintou barre de la fève à la tablette
andres est à les sélectionner les
producteurs de ces fèves de cacao en
amérique du sud au pérou en république
dominicaine en équateur ou au venezuela
sa terre natale cuisine les transforme
dans sa chocolaterie à paris donc cette
fin on va la prendre on va la mettre et
sauvé un faux nom des lycéens fort
poteau riffier la torréfaction c'est
simplement la cuisson des l'éphèbe du
cacao après la cuisson et au bac ont
cassé la fef et et on va séparer délais
et coffe et ça on va broyer et un
première fois après on va les mettre sur
cette machine qu'est ce qu'on lançait
moonan pour faire de la farine doublé et
sûrement sûr que ça devienne liquidambar
ajouté et les sucres et après ça va
devenir un chocolat quand le sucre et la
vienne mélangez grâce à un savoir faire
et quelques secrets de fabrication
remontera les gens qu'il a plus de
variété qui est la fermentation peut
changer le goût du chocolat cacao c'est
un peu comme les ventes comme tous les
nourritures qui l'avait variété que
c'est important de découvrir tous les
goûts qui ont assuré qu'un
là il ya quatre tablettes cat sort
différent il a quatre variétés et aussi
il y a trois pays différents ça c'est
cette variété ça c'est en variétés qui
s'appelle est entré au cac qui vient de
la colombie ici on parle cru a room
saveurs équilibre on retrouve le goût
brütsch du cacao
6 filles
et 6 délicieux la cedh soient pas plus
maintenant vraiment ces farines même les
ganaches et son tour
andres a été récompensé pour son travail
en france ils sont environ 80
chocolatier à travailler eux mêmes la
fève
la plupart utilisent un chocolat déjà
transformé c'est ce qu'on appelle le
chocolat de couverture
les chocolatiers l'agrément ensuite et
façonnent leur création
alors yannick alléno on vous connaît
curieux touche à tout mais quel a été le
déclic pour vous lancer comme ça parce
que c'est pas le coeur de votre métier
dans le chocolat est en plus un chocolat
sans beurre sans sucre et sans crème
donc un peu radical
radical certainement pas en plaisir
d'ailleurs je vous en ai ramené un petit
peu
on en parle sans goûter c'est quand même
un problème oui vous l'avez d'orgie de
chocolat dont il faut bien le voir c'est
magnifique et
et et non parce qu'avec aurélien rivoire
qui m'ont mon pâtissier avec lesquels on
travaille ensemble depuis dix ans et
dans notre cadre de réformes de cuisine
on avait on a tous les deux à ces
appétits qui dit pâtissier chocolatier
glacier confiseur
alors la confiserie on a réussi à le
faire sans utilisation de sucre le
dernier traité qui a été fait sur le
coup sûr le sur le confie a été fait par
nostradamus en 15 155 depuis pas eu
forcément de travail nouveau là dessus
donc on a inventé les confient sans
sucre ou alors on appelle ça le confit
de fruits et ensuite avec fruits confits
son sucre pourquoi on soit clair
pourquoi j'étais au travail que
nous devons les fruits qui est non non
on fait un travail nouveau avec de l'eau
de bouleau c'est le l'arbre
c'est ouais de fin j'ai vu vous en
mettez partout lallouet partout alors
faisons le sucre est naturellement
exactement fin il ya un pouvoir sucrant
assaisonnant conservateur aussi
cristallisant ce qui remplace le sucre
on a un indice 1 à 10 je dirais
glycémique de 7% versus 100 % par
rapport au sucre ce qui fait quand on
aime quand je mangeais un confit de
fruits comme ça je pas besoin de boire 3
le dos des toqués a un goût sucré quand
même passé seize années assez sucré
c'est sucré c'est sucré et ça choquera
de gastronomie sert qu'à l'intérêt on va
les mêmes les praslin on met plus
surprenant donc on essaye comme ça alors
c'est pas parce que le sucre et je suis
pas un ennemi du sucre mais en tout cas
je trouvais que c'était une évolution
intéressante l'autre évolution
intéressant cela dit ces tendances et
les pâtisseries sans sucre les nationaux
sur ce qu'il ya basta on la combat comme
l'a compris que j'avais une l'a dit une
addiction au sucre quand même donc on
essaie de limiter le jour suivant les
usages du sucre dans l'alimentation
générale vous avez des sucres cachés de
partout dans les premiers temps non mais
par toulon la moment donné il faut il
faut aussi qu'on travaille pour trouver
des solutions pour que l'ensemble ça va
profiter à l'industrie 1 que l'ensemble
de l'alimentation
donc ça vient de la grande gastronomie
mais la grande évolution finalement
c'est pas le chocolat on a vu
notre chocolatier fantastique faire des
décrochages des produits à travailler
notre ait nicolas berger 4 400 400 m² à
400 mètres du but du laboratoire que
nous avons choisi le roi donc vous par
rapport aux autres chocolatiers qu'on a
vu vous torréfié pas vous fait vous
achetez déjà un chocolat grand mais
c'est le meilleur à côté de moi je vais
pas commencer à le faire on appelle le
chocolat de couverture exactement lui
très bien selon moi pas de travail
derrière c'est l'intérieur c'est la
sauce
mais si vous voulez faire une évolution
il faut il faut le comprendre le seul
truc qu'on doit faire évoluer pour faire
évoluer les choses c'est la sauce et
l'associé transversale donc ce qu'on met
dans une petite enveloppe chocolatées
c'est une ganache alors une ganache
l effet de façon traditionnelle de crème
de beurre etc nous on n'est pas tout ça
on mais est ce que le travail qu'on a
fait sur les sauces et l'extraction
alors là on voit par exemple certaines
de vos du trèfle alors ça c'est c'est
formidable ce qu'il ya c'est un chocolat
double coque c'est dans la partie
supérieure vous avez toute la texture
donc ça croque et c est un sou vous avez
la sauce donc nous on travaille avec des
herbes sauvages on fait des trucs comme
ça et qui sont liées au chocolat malgré
tout
parce que c'est les petits eux à plat là
c'est les confits censure c'est l'orangé
qui a été trempés dans du chocolat de
couverture
c'est quoi ça c'est les yeux à plat
c'est la 2e place à l'édition donc on
est sur des praslin des praslin et
c'était 1-0 sucre de bouleau partout
partout partout on n'utilise que de ça
et vous allez voir c'est à ces zones et
c'est assez intéressant et non non on
s'amuse beaucoup avec ça et du coup on
s'est dit pourquoi pas encore une fois
c'est un sujet entreprises et avec
aurélien dans son évolution de carrière
je me suis associé avec lui pour faire
cette maison qui est sublime c'est
dingue parce que je
non mais par contre vous voyez que la
vôtre autobus et mixera sera au plus bas
grâce à cela et donc on a alors scellé
chocolat frey on les conserve évidemment
moins que des choses voilà qui sont le
sucre est un concept revin et 50% sur
vous trouvez la plupart du temps c'est
quand même assez assez important et vous
vous savez d'où viennent vos fèves oui
bien sûr
maintenant je suis allé sur place encore
une fois on a le plus grand spécialiste
français qui est à 400 mène à côté de la
maison c'est exactement c'est lui qui a
huit ou le système chocolaterie ducasse
en place puis il a décidé de faire son
propre travail son propre sa propre
entreprise j'ai acheté deux laboratoires
je savais pas qu'il était là et donc il
vous livre et nous livre en gros feutre
et donc on sait ça vient ça vient du
père ou du venezuela
il va chercher ses fèves de partout nous
on fait un truc aussi très un travail
extraordinaire sur j'aime pas ce mot
parce que je crois qu'il va faire quand
on entre ou un autre sur les déchets
verts les enveloppes de la fève de cacao
qui sont généralement dispersés dans
dans les autres cas le grué de cacao bon
c'est la faire
éclater comme ça mais il ya les
enveloppes il ya un truc qui est on est
en train de faire c'est le travail sur
le mucilage le musée hcc quand on ouvre
une fève de cacao il ya une partie
blanche que là dedans qui entourent l'a
fait pour la protéger et ça les
agriculteurs les répandent sur leurs
terres c'est hyper acide
c'est en train de transformer énormément
l'acidité des sols et de faire des gros
dégâts sur leurs plantations donc nous
on a fait un travail sur la récupération
du mucilage pour le traiter et le
réinsérer dans le chocolat c'est un
produit qui est formidable parce qu est
ce que vous êtes inquiet sur l'avenir du
chocolat qui bouleversement climatique
le réchauffement on dit que ça pourrait
éradiquer une partie de la production
actuelle est que dans quelques années et
faire monter les prix et même à terme de
moins en moins de chocolat dans tous les
cas le choc est tel que vous l'aimez
déjà il ya de plus en plus de
consommation
et puis ensuite il ya effectivement 4
par personne passionnant et il ya en
fait
je suis pas inquiet que pour le chocolat
je suis inquiet pour la vie je suis
inquiet pour beaucoup de choses donc il
faut il faut réapprendre à consommer
différemment j'ai pris mes skis cet
hiver à courchevel sur une maison là-bas
j'ai fait le tour un peu des restaurants
à la piste est très honnêtement je suis
assez effaré de ce que j'ai vu de côte
de boeuf wagyu de king crab etc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui qui qui proposent
ce genre de cuisine alors qu'en france
on a des produits extraordinaires mais
des muscles de boeuf par exemple qui
peuvent être utilisés c'est
impressionnant tout ce qui peut y avoir
quand on peut consommer et qu'on utilise
plus part peut-être par par simplicité
par etc donc il faut tout ce qu'on se
remette au boulot pour qu'on ait un plus
plus local j'ai fait le comparatif entre
les cinq mille recettes d'escoffier et
5000 recettes des plus grands chefs
contemporain dont je vais partir et
globalement on utilise touche à peu ou
prou 30% de ce qu'ils utilisaient dans
le temps donc le problème vient aussi de
là c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
réapprenne à utiliser des morceaux des
réflexes et choses comme ça qui qui
feront en sorte sur la planète ira mieux
allez on passe au dessert parce qu'il
est déjà c'est le péché mignon
alors j'allais dire voici venu le temps
du sucré mais qui yannick alléno faut
pas dire ça parce que ce décès récents
d'audi pas très sucré ya plus de sucre
bon en tout les cas c'est un dessert de
oufa rhubarbe cuite en croûte de sucre
il faudra nous expliquer sorbet à
l'oseille et fine gavotte alors c'est un
assemblage absolument gourmands une
plante la rhubarbe
la croûte de sucre vous nous expliquerez
le sorbet à l'oseille ça aussi c'est
franchement osé et puis cette fine
crêpes bretonnes la gavotte croit steve
marques déposées mois la gavotte non
l'avait récupérée ah non non ce n'est
pas une marque de la gavotte sur vont
déposer enfin la gavotte et 1 et 1 est
une préparation culinaire française et
une petite crêpe et sa très concrète
tout filmé tout fini il est très
difficile à faire d'ailleurs
expliquez-nous ce dessert alors oui
c'est ça la dent mais restant je
continue à utiliser du sucre je suis pas
en train de dire j'ai banni ce problème
et y en a le bruit alors je fais un
mélange de blanc d'oeuf et de sucre gras
salés des gros sucre on achète et je
mets la rhubarbe dedans et je là comme
un sarcophage de sucre je la mets au
four à 160 degrés pour la cuire et vous
l'a laissé dehors toute la nuit vous la
récupérer le lendemain c'est
extraordinaire c'est ce qui lui donne
cette couleur absolument wells était sûr
j'allais voir et d'ailleurs je fais ça
aussi du foie gras en croûte de sucre en
coûte de sucre ouais j'en tire le foie
gras d'algues d'algues et je mets en
croûte de sucre et ça ça sucre non on
n'a pas du tout goût du sucre avec le
nom on regarde la tension en fait le
produit comme les croûte de sel
bon la croûte de sel le poisson quand
vous montrez aucune pression c'est 19
passagers il a besoin là c'est pareil
pardon la rhubarbe va prendre tout ce
qu'elle a besoin a rappelé la croûte de
sucre quand l'envié aux téléspectateurs
un blanc d'oeuf et du sucre des
graffitis sur des petits grains dessus
comme ça tout et vous mettez juste le
blanc d'oeuf nécessaire pour sa façon un
agglomérat en fait est là dedans vous
mettez ça sur votre rhubarbe il faut un
peu la passe et enlever les fils un peu
saoul et rhubarbe oui il faut la
première feuille on du fil à retordre
hélas à l'oseille en glace s'est passé
assez tôt
mélanger comme ça les textures et les
adore la mer en fait ce qui tient le
goût c'est la contradiction de la
salinité de l'amertume dans le vent donc
et on retrouve ça donc j'essaie toujours
d'aller chercher comme ça sert des plats
servis à la carte pavillon pas venu donc
c'est vraiment un dessert de pas
l'instant on est gâté on peut le dire
pas lâcher
en pleine campagne présidentielle alors
nous nous intéressons aux coutumes de
l'elysée et aux habitudes des
présidences et le quiz présidentielle
alors la légion d'honneur pour votre ami
paul bocuse c'était une première pour un
cuisinier sous la vème république quel
est le président gourmand qui lui a
remis cette distinction valéry giscard
d'estaing oui françois mitterrand
jacques chirac ou nicolas sarkozy valéry
giscard d'estaing il appelle à soulever
j'ai eu d'ailleurs
il a son sort dont je pense pas il est
pas comme ça mais j'ai aussi non non il
a fait beau à faire sauver yeux il a
fait une soupe consommer de boeuf et des
truffes et ou en croûte feuilleter comme
ça qu'il a servi très longtemps et
c'était à 75,7 les jours d'honneur et
c'était la première depuis 1919 depuis
escoffier qui lui aussi a été décoré
alors pour terminer cette émission
montre toujours à nos invités le film
qu'ils apprécient le plus et vous vous
avez parlé du grand restaurant avec
louis de funès alors c'est assez
étonnant puisque la semaine dernière à
votre place nous recevions jean françois
piège qui a le le même choix que vous
qui en a donné le nom à son restaurant
pourquoi pourquoi ce choix mais moi j'ai
une affection particulière pour ce film
pourquoi parce que le doyen c'est le
l'endroit où a été tourné en restant et
puis je trouve que j'ai refait la danse
de de funès pour les voeux en 2014-2015
chez plus et je m'aperçois à quel point
de finesse et est souple et grands
danseurs et on s'est beaucoup amusés
avec ça et voilà le grand restaurant ça
symbolise notre profession aussi c'est
c'était l'époque l'époque de ses
restaurants quand il ya bien masqué pour
mettre en défaut ces équipes leur
apprendra finalement à ceux à se tenir à
se comporter cetera devant la clientèle
c'est extraordinairement drôle et très
très très heureux merci beaucoup et
yannick allait aussi d'avoir partagé ce
repas